it's time to talk about the serious news
cat that extra fee ya cat-tastrophe
perfect thank you have a catastrophic
news essay right yes you did
good job let me uh let me tell you
something we have the stories in the
Daily Mail pet cats have a catastrophic
impact on local wildlife when allowed to
roam roam free as they kill up to 10
times more prey than wild cats study
claims now hold on was this fact checked
I'm just kidding please wait something
funny is this written by the funny thing
was it says they found that baby bunnies
and birds on a driveway were the most at
risk
yeah have you ever met a cat this rule
looking out the window ok baby bunnies
have you ever met a cat this is funny
though because no this is serious in so
humans have humans love cats everybody
knows it right well the cats they
scratch you and get their their cat
scratch fever toxin no no so you fall in
love that's true well no that's a great
thing well there there poop is in their
claws so they scratch you that you love
them okay so no so here's the thing
here's the thing human thing humans love
bringing cats around with them and
they've been doing it for a long time so
when European colonists went to New
Zealand they brought a bunch of cats
with them because dude let's admit cats
are funny you know they lay around all
day they're lazy and smug knock your
glass over yeah like like there's a
really funny video where a cat is on the
table and he's like smacking the glass
and it gets to the edge and then he
looks up and sees the person looking at
him and then he slowly takes his other
hand it's not pushing it back onto the
mil table that's hilarious
you know things funny about cats is that
they're extremely like their murderous
they are but they're too small to murder
us there's only laughs they're the only
domesticated animal that will survive
after we we go because they killed us
well because they yeah they kill for fun
but they because they could they can
survive their hunt yes they don't lose
that oh I think I actually can't be
domesticated they're not domesticated
what I mean they don't we have them they
don't answer to their name there there
are there are that's not true at all
well that's not true at all they're ours
you let them out you let them out
they're good bucko plays fetch and
managed to it might not be gone forever
but they're good they can go survive a
dog a dog won't survive out there listen
that's not true it depends on the dog
not a pug all right right yeah you're
right it'll depend on the door listen
listen listen
okay so humans getting these big old
boats right hmm and what happens is
pigeons come along yeah because pigeons
hop on the you know there's food rats
and cats and so they go to New Zealand
and the cats jump out and what are the
firt what's the first thing they do they
go with their claws and they start
mowing down things for fun
yeah so I read I was reading this thing
that said that if humans all got
obliterated just like wiped out tonight
yeah cats would survive they would down
at the planet because of the only other
species that kill for fun I'll just kill
it and like flick it away and laughs you
know I you know they'd go run kill
everything smaller than them in New
Zealand they did well and so there was
this dude I interviewed named Gareth I
think it's name was Gareth Morgan okay
and apparently he said it's time to like
put all our cats down and people yeah
it's like it's time to kill them all I
don't think said it like that but it's
because cats wipe out small species for
no reason they're done brutal murderers
no murder machines little murder and I
think you know what you know I think is
that's great humans see a little bit of
us in them like they want to kill us but
they can't but they can't but so how
endearing that is that murderous look in
their eye so here's another interesting
fact though I don't know if this is
still true but I read that's people
search for dogs twice as much as they
search for cats on the Internet really
because to mean that people search for
cats uh-huh you know but it's actually
dogs apparently okay so anyway let's get
to this story and read about pet cats
destroying local wildlife when allowed
to roam free killing up to 10 times more
prey than wild cats this is what's crazy
is because domesticated cats are like
it's it's almost like the nobles of like
the it's like the ivory tower elites
hunting the wild cats are like hunting
for need yeah and the the snooty elite
1% cats who live in luxury are like I
just want to kill I just wanted to
trying to love sharpened clock new
needle fingers I just love killing
researchers from North Carolina State
University branded domestic cats a
conversation conservation concern
because they kill billions of native
prey each year moggies kill it at ten
times more wildlife in their wild cat
cousins according to the team who say
keeping them indoors could be the answer
why do you want your cat to run around
the wilderness anyway they get hurt like
out where we live there's birds of prey
circling around outside and why do
people get snatched up pretty big birds
out there I don't know they're vicious
little little mf'er so maybe they'll
snatch those birds and take them inside
imagine if the cat dragged in oh my gosh
the Eagles over I don't know
we have hawks others are huge yeah they
are pretty big yeah they tracked the
movements and counted the prey of 925
pet cats from the US UK Australia in New
Zealand as part of their study birds
landing on driveways and baby rabbits
munching on lawn grass were some of the
animals in most mo most in danger from
house cats left from outside okay I'm
gonna have to say like I don't think you
needed to invest in a grant to research
that that's a big stupid like oh you
mean the baby bunnies are being killed
by cats for hey hey money well-spent
yeah I don't know if this is true but I
once read that they spent like 40 grand
in doing they gave a forty thousand
dollar grant to investigate whether fish
feel pain and they concluded that fish
feel pain yeah you need to do it you can
you take a face you poke it and it
reacts and swims away like what what do
whatever you want to call that the
researchers focused on the ecological
impact of house cats as opposed to feral
cats and enlisted hundreds of pet owners
to track them the team monitored the
distances traveled by the pet cats which
spent their days both indoors and
outdoors using GPS tracking devices
owners also recorded the number of dead
critters they brought home which was
then divided by the area in which the
cats hunted some adjustments were made
to the prey prey count as cats do not
necessarily bring all their kills home
oh so they artificially added some a
margin of error margin
okay so are you saying that this is
biased against cats yes they're smearing
cats yeah it's clearly a cat smear all
right so here's they said no nerds
reported no one no cat
written by a dog I'm telling you owners
reported their pets killed an average of
3.5 times a month similar or higher than
their pet similar or higher than the per
animal ecological impact of wild
carnivores but the effect is amplified
by the high density of cats and
neighborhoods pet cats kill an average
of fourteen point two to thirty eight
point nine per 100 acres per year much
of the damage to wildlife was done and
disturbed habitats like housing
developments this effect was mostly
concentrated close to the cats homes
with most of their movements within 300
foot radius of their house younger cats
in those living in rural areas had
slightly larger home ranges researchers
concluded domestic cats have a greater
ecological impact than native predators
concentrated closer to home since they
are fed cat food pets kill fewer prey
per day than wild predators but their
home ranges were so small that this
effect on local prey ends up getting
really concentrated add to this the
unnaturally high density of pet cats in
some areas and the risk to birds and
small mammals gets even worse look at
this picture they put as a bird behind
the cat but do they want it look it
looks like the cat is you know looking
at slips looking at the mouth we found
that house cats have a two to ten time
larger impact on wildlife than wild
predators a striking effect see I didn't
even know most people let their cats
outside yeah I mean I mean I grew up
with random cats like I remember like
the first pet I had was a dog and a cat
and cat never went outside my friend's
growing up they had cats cats stayed
indoors there was never like only until
recently that someone I know someone who
has a little cat door and the cat would
come and go as they please and I was
like well that's cool yeah and they
would go out and come back like five
hours later and be all like yeah yeah I
killed something I had friends just
leave their window open and I was like
aren't you worried about the cat and
then guess what happened but cat aids
FIV yeah
seriously yeah yeah Wow cat AIDS but
also apparently it got scratched by
another cat who had cat AIDS and I know
YouTube try get mad at me for saying
that but it's it's real yeah yeah it's
called FIV it's like was it fifi feline
him you know something virus or whatever
yep
see when I actually the last time I
lived in Philly we had a cat and she got
out one time and our neighbor stole the
cat yeah my mom swears she saw the cat
in the window like looking at us and she
like ran over there and was like I want
my cat and she was like nope woman had
like six cats already but lady she was a
cat lady and she took our cat I'm sure
she did do you guys know what
toxoplasmosis is yeah she's got it she
did what if like yeah totally I wonder
if all cat ladies have are infected have
you ever seen the videos so basically
it's a parasite goes in your brain or
something and there's crazy videos where
like a rat will run to a cat and not be
scared yeah and the cat goes like whack
kills it yeah because it was infected
because cats have this parasite yeah and
it could infect humans and it makes you
love cats yeah well I think it's it's it
was originally made evolved I can't talk
tonight sorry it evolved to make cats
rats less afraid of cats and to give
cats the upper hand well it's it's
symbiotic though it's it's a parasite
right so I'm guessing that if humans
have a similar reaction to as rats do
then humans will have a greater affinity
for cats as well which is really
interesting but here's the thing I read
that it also causes schizophrenia it
does yeah so you have these exactly it's
like a real thing yeah where these women
just you get a cat you get infected and
then they love cats and keep getting
more and then it's like on The Simpsons
they start screaming and throwing the
cats you know you know that lady on The
Simpsons yeah yeah like I said I
remember I didn't know that was a real
thing they start throwing cat oh no this
is a joke all right
I think did someone on Simpsons like
have a cat launcher and she starts using
like I stopped watching The Simpsons a
long time no this this creepy like what
if what if you can cure crazy cat lady
who knows well I mean would they want to
be cured wouldn't want to be you'd have
to do it like well but that's like
that's like brain slugs like your brain
is infected by a parasite making you
love cats you cure them it's like
they're like zombies that's the cat's
cat trying to one-up us we've been like
oh you're so cute you can't kill us and
they're like I just infected you while
you slept last night
well so it's your face there's no people
don't realize man you ever see your cat
lick its butthole yep yeah uh-huh and
then it licks its body and then you walk
up all giggly going whoo and you put the
key in the key when you give it and then
there's just like the corona virus yeah
and you get you got Katy poop all over
your face don't even realize it and then
you start buttering your toast and
you're laughing and you're like boom now
you're cat lady thank you for that dude
new it's crazy though think about it
that means cat lady is a contagious
disease parasitic infection you can
catch cat lady is are you saying that's
the new the new name of this virus cat
lady cat lady disease cat lady disease
right now everybody's freaking out of
eld over over you know the bat virus the
what it's called now the bat virus some
people called it really trying to figure
out a name for this yeah as many
meanwhile we haven't been paying
attention to the real threat cats
Toxoplasma get you it's not now then one
day yeah you know what man I think in
reality it's like what I read was that
humans like big eyes and small heads or
whatever so oh yeah but but I personally
find it cute that like you know bucko
our cat for instance is a vicious bucko
you're pronouncing his name wrong that's
his proper name and I had his name
legally changed yeah I did I went to the
place and had his name changed ship yeah
to what I called him he wrote it down
what you're a serious yeah you switched
to the Oh in the you yeah that is
unacceptable
we talked about this no no no he has a
proper name he told me anyway he said
Tim keeps dead naming me and I'm upset
oh my god oh no
dead his name is bucko and I did not
name him but he's named he's named you
clean your room bucko
yeah that's his proper name but anyway
the point is
his name's boo boo he's a vicious little
murderer and he's always like you know
he tries to appear threatening and it's
funny cuz it's like he's not he's not
he's got his claws and he's like he
tries to look all angry and smug all the
time he turns on his back and shows you
it's weird and then he rolls on the
ground that likes his belly rubbed yeah
he's like a dog he really is like a dog
kind of yeah yeah if you throw the whole
bird toy he runs and grabs it brings it
back he responds to his sometimes
respond
so when you say bucko and he's like he
doesn't respond it's it make resentence
not his name
so you yell his name and he comes here
comes mm-hmm I mean now that he's got
that that that the the carrier yeah he's
like goes inside and all right it's the
memory foam mattress I got for that it's
you put a memory foam mattress in this
yeah okay I'm pretty sure y'all are
infected with ion see there there I
don't want to bring this up because I
hate bring this up but when I went vegan
I swear
cats all animals smelled me differently
that I can that they can smell that I
don't eat meat anymore dogs definitely
can
I definitely and I do where animals act
differently around me I heard a crazy
story it's it's true like I'm around a
lot of animals my mom has a couple
horses she had many dogs I've got a lot
of animals all I said I read this crazy
story that there was a dude who went to
I think he was in Vietnam and he ate dog
okay and when he came back dot and all
these dogs would like growl at him
really they would smell like growl at
him in like get away from them he was
the threat they could smell that he ate
dog yeah that make like dude dogs can
smell if you have tumors like if you're
bout to have a seizure and stuff that's
what I was alluding to like they can
tell that I am no longer a threat at all
I'm not interests I'm not something that
eats their type
and they're like oh you're cool you're
cool you don't eat mean like I mean
bucko eats nothing but me eat you laugh
but he can smell that I don't eat meat
no I think he guaranteed he's a smug
little vicious murderer and yeah like
he's probably thinking himself like what
a pathetic human he doesn't even even
meet he's so cute though that's what's
cute about it's like little supervillain
who can't really hurt you
yeah I just look at him and I go oh I'm
so Jesus don't you know no but the dog
thing's crazy like basically the story
is that if you eat dog the dogs can
smell it yeah surprise me know like bite
you and like get away from you're a
threat or not and tell that you eat are
kind not not even that great away it's
like how dare you I think it's a little
more basic than that I think you're a
murderer you're a dog killer and they
can smell it on you yeah you eat you eat
our kind so you're no longer a human
that I can trust man creepy thanks for
checking out this segment from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show every
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
sometimes an hour or two and we do have
a full live recorded version of the show
that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8:00 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next show
you